yeah welcome to this video playing as
power of MH 99 and well maybe but he
hasn't moved yet ok now maybe let's go
for the Trump offski I don't really know
much about it but there's a new book
coming out about this opening when
English Grand Master Richard put down
yeah maybe the trop is an opening to
consider that some it's certainly quite
solid I mean it's not like black can get
an super great game with easy easy means
hmm ok I wonder about f4 here is this a
possible try it for some sort of
souped-up Stonewall 95 as a possibility
ok I it's just try to develop quickly
mmm ok I always need to check this
capture and 95 this kind of ideas if I
go Queenie to let's say CD ed 95 should
be seven tween here or yeah it's not a
big deal
hmm Wow rookie aid I didn't really
consider that move him let's improve the
position and prepare you for I what
didn't
yeah I don't know we simply placed some
some moves instantly without pretty much
I don't think without considering too
much what is going on okay I'll play a
45 hmm f was hanging but taking that is
risky yep didn't consider it probably
and now just see five should be here
should be excellent Queenie phone or
take first yeah this looks um like white
shirt should be a should be an excellent
shape here go Queenie form it's also
good
what up or just take e seven I can take
care forum Bishop g3 almost a good okay
let's do that I'm really unsure what to
play
yeah no I'm threatening Knight f6 with
the winning attacker check this is a
move you should just play without
calculating it must be working
everything else would be here usually
unfair yeah i have always amazed simply
moving everything instantly without ever
thinking about anything okay but i think
it will be mated now Queen g4 don't see
any way to defend this
Quincy for Queen h5 rogue f3 g3 this is
too much no way to defend that this is a
case where this is f6 pawn the bishop
only five the pawn on d4 they simply cut
the board in two I have all everything
as in the attack the bishop on these
three the bishop 45 and here the rook is
coming as well and there's also the
simple threat Queenie four punches in
fact made in two moves and there's even
this one checkmate it's a pin yeah yeah
I simply don't understand the time
management I mean I'm playing too slow
it's it's it's well known yeah but how
can you play off those movements cindy i
mean it's it's obvious wide is brewing a
big attack here and he played rupee 8
weakening f7 and so on and all this
coming coming without any consideration
how to defend it and here it's already
beyond repair i mean even if the
computer is not so optimistic it's just
on 0.6 or something it's very tough to
defend this i got everything in the
attack now yeah this is already winning
the apt computer gives it is winning
also 96 and it's it's it's too much
check this one this is not defensible
and the mace that is only giving it's a
plus 3 it wants to play Knight takes c3
with plus 3 yeah I guess if you let it
calculate somewhat longer our now it's
on platform if you let it calculate
somewhat longer it would even see a maid
I don't see that I don't see him I don't
see black defending against medium it's
not possible and maybe it was some
desperado stuff queen d 5 g 20 so
but otherwise it's just them just just
made thanks for watching